the fight against the new omicron
variant in senegal starts here at a
health center in downtown dakar where
doses of the covid19 vaccines are
available
it's not because we have a vaccine that
we're immune we need to keep protective
measures and protect those around us
it's not over
at a two-day peace and security form
held in dakar on monday south africa's
president cyril ramaphosa accused rich
countries of creating health apartheid
i have personally really been
disappointed
in the approach that the rich countries
have taken on the issue of vaccines
firstly they hoarded vaccines
they ordered more vaccines than their
populations required
and when we wanted vaccines
they just kept you know giving us the
crumbs from their table
and the greed that they demonstrated
is something that is quite quite
disappointing indeed
particularly when they say they are our
partners
the pandemic overshadowed the seventh
peace and security forum held here which
welcomed heads of state intelligence
officers and military chiefs
usually discussions at the forum
revolves around greater military
cooperation between western nations and
african countries but with western
countries breaking their promise to
supply vaccines and their unwillingness
to wave patterns to allow people here to
make their own
trust is eroding with some nations
looking at new partnerships
to help the fight against covet in
africa china announced it's sending one
billion doses of vaccines
on the fight against armed groups in the
sahel region nigeria's president
admitted that al-qaeda affiliates are in
some places better equipped than the
security forces of some countries in
west africa
following increased attacks mali is
seeking help from the russian
mercenaries working for wagner the
private military company
that's why countries like mali we have
decided to go more and more for
diversification of our partnerships we
can work with china we can work with
russia
also at the forum delegates from western
nations reiterated their goodwill and
intentions but countries such as south
africa and senegal say that's not good
enough
vaccines made in africa for africans is
what they want almost a quarter of a
million africans are reported to have
died of the virus so far the message
here is those death were preventable if
only victims had access to vaccines
nicholas hawk al-jazeera dakar